[Music]
hey what's up guys My Name Is AO and
welcome to Minecraft okay so here's the
deal I am pretty much finishing year 12
right now and I'm so busy and I thought
you know what I need to take regular
breaks um between my studies and I
thought why not take that take that
opportunity while I'm having a break to
actually make a video for you guys and
um particularly you know Minecraft I
haven't played Minecraft in a year um
last time I actually played it was uh
when I was live streaming it with you
guys right on the stream on twitch.tv um
that was a lot of fun uh and also I made
a video about still like on my old
Channel I'll actually link the video
down in the in the description but um I
made a video on how um on how uh you
know if I should make a Minecraft series
or not and you guys really wanted one so
here you here you have it I guess here's
a Minecraft series for you guys so um
we're just going to make a new world I'm
talking really fast cuz I'm trying to
chernos world right that sounds cool
yeah chernos world chernos world will
work um I don't have uh I haven't played
in a while so I have no idea what's Chad
off uh generate structures let's make
the seed chero all right so you guys can
have like the exact same seed as me um
and well type default what are they oh
super flat large biomes default uh bonus
chests don't know what that is I have no
idea what this stuff is so we're just
going to leave it at
default and we're going to make it
hardcore so that if we die that's it the
series ends when we die so um create a
new world all right I have no idea
what's going to happen like apart from
it probably making us a new world I
don't know I haven't played Minecraft
since like 1.0 I didn't think so I I
don't know you have to like eat I think
now all right so here we have it um
looking pretty good let's see what uh
I've still got my like my suit on cuz
I'm a boss um I we might have some
problems here with uh yeah
hang on a minute we're running on really
low Graphics aren't
we uh snooper settings what is
this
ooh
cool um let's see video settings so
smooth lighting fancy render on normal
that should be enough I don't want to go
too hard cuz I'm recording with fraps
and this computer is kind of
old so yeah we're pulling about 50
frames per second so that's that's fine
all right so I don't even know what to
do like I mean you I guess we got
to where is the sun dude this biome is
crazy well all right so let's um let's
take a look at let's just get some wood
first you know what it's one thing I
know how to do and that's get wood cuz
wood is the Pinnacle of um Pinnacle what
do that word mean I don't even know see
getting wood there we go achievement
get I'm going to use the flower here so
um yeah I mean I'm not sure how often
I'm going to be able to make these
videos for you guys but hey I mean I I
don't know um that's up to you guys
actually no it's up to me it's up to
like I don't know I'm just picturing
like maybe after like 2 hours of study
I'll take like 10 minutes or so to make
a video and again this will basically go
for I guess 10 minutes um I'm not sure
how long uh until we can actually do
something I guess I'm not sure when to
stop a video that's sort of the problem
um like
Minecraft isn't something like you know
if I was making like a Call of Duty
video you know one game would equal one
video but here yeah I don't know I guess
when it gets when something like
exciting happens I'll just stop it so
you guys will be like inclined um to
watch the next video which from a
business perspective is actually quite a
good technique
um I'm just kidding around with you guys
but seriously that's probably what I'll
do um
anyway so I don't even know what to talk
about right now um what you want to do
in Minecraft and you guys probably know
this I mean who doesn't I was watching a
video actually on Minecraft the other
day and it was about a guy who um was
making a Minecraft video and he uh he
said you know he was like okay how to
survive the first night in Minecraft and
I and I look at the upload date cuz I'm
like well Sur this must be from like
2010 and I'm I'm I'm looking at it and
it's September 7 2012 and I'm like dude
if people don't know how to survive the
first night in Minecraft by now like God
help them cuz I mean like legit I I I
was really confused but um yeah so I'm
not going to teach you guys how to
freaking survive the first night you
know what you have to do you have to get
some wood that's pretty much all you
need um I'm not sure if they again I
have no idea I'll probably start doing
things or trying things that you guys
will probably be like dude no that was
taken out in like beta version 0.7 or
something I don't know um and yeah
perhaps you're right but what are these
things Birch sapling interesting uh and
perhaps you're right with that you know
I've no idea but um I'm going to look
look around for a nice place to build my
house
here I don't have any mods in inst if
you guys have any suggestions for mods
that I should probably install that
wouldn't really subtract from this
awesome gameplay experience um then let
me know I know food is another big deal
that's one thing I do I do know all
right so let's take a look
at wow okay it's quite a quite vast
landscape and I I I want water whoa
better not fall off I'm on Hardcore as
well so Health probably won't regenerate
and if I die then this world gets
deleted so yeah all that was not good
okay I want I want actual like a I want
actual water sources like a SE or
something you know what I
mean so I guess we'll find a SE
um oh no Health did reg yeah health does
regenerate ooh ooh ooh pumpkins what are
they good for again jackar lanterns I
know they make jackar
lanterns um yeah I remember um that you
could you could make coal out of wood
like you could make charcoal out of wood
all you needed was to torch wood um
basically so I'll show you guys how to
do that in case you don't know but um
I'll probably have to do have to do that
if I don't find any coal fast enough cuz
night is coming um speaking of like
stuff coming um oh that sounds pretty
bad but uh didn't mean it that way boys
did not mean it that way um ooh o that's
cool
um what I meant is uh Game of Thrones
you know winter is coming has just
reminded me of Game of Thrones I haven't
I actually haven't watched anything past
the first season so I really have to get
onto that when I finished school um I've
got like a list of we're probably going
to park ourselves over
here um I hear zombies as well oh I hear
water as well but well let's get okay
let's just this will be like our first
um Bassy thing oh whoops my bad we need
to oh there what there's there's a
difference oric wood and Birchwood I'm
guessing they just look different right
let's just see
so if we
make yeah looks like they just look
different can you mix Woods y all right
cool so no no real
problem uh let's also
make um oh we need um yeah so let's make
some
um oh it's planks my
bad yep okay they're not interchangeable
either let's make um some sticks and
what's the other thing we need sticks
and that's pretty much it I think cuz if
we make sticks we can um make this
little thing and then we can start
mining our
way oh yes the music hang on got to make
sure music's on
100% love
it all right what is this is that
gravel oh it is doesn't look like a
gravel all right I guess we'll just
spend our first night here I really want
to find find a place with um that's
taking a while let's just make a make a
stone um pick one thing I do want to
really do is actually find that place
next to the beach where I can actually
pop my
um
oops is to find that place next to the
beach where I can pop my uh house so
I'll keep definitely keep searching for
that but um
yeah if you guys have any suggestions
for topics I could talk about cuz I mean
I'm thinking like a series might be a
great opportunity to actually do like a
question and answer session or something
while I'm you know mining so um be sure
to follow me on Twitter um there you'll
find the latest updates from our Premier
directors and the and the rest of the
Mach respawn team that's from um o
creeper that's not good that's from um
that's from like ages ago I remember
watching Machin videos ages ago and they
had um you know that be sure to follow
us on Twitter outro unlike every video
it was crazy everyone hated it and uh
pretty much much no one follow them on
Twitter because of that I remember
comments that were like you know I I
won't be following you on Twitter
Mission um but yeah uh what I was going
to say is um you can tweet me um or just
leave a comment you know it's up to you
really I mean I do read comments anyway
so just leave a suggestion leave like a
question or answer uh I don't know no
don't leave the answer that's that's my
job just leave a question or something
and I'll um I'll see if I can make this
a bit more interesting
um yeah just general not even like
questions just topics to talk about I
mean I'm sure a lot of you guys would
like me to talk about stuff like Java
and uh my thoughts on I don't know game
development
um um a guy the other day asked me what
my thoughts on Windows 8 were and that's
I don't know like I haven't used it but
I I don't like it at the moment like
from what I've seen which is not much I
don't like it so that's I don't know
will I be upgrading to it to it h i
don't even know man like
maybe but
um I can't I can't just I don't know I'm
really happy with Windows 7 there's
nothing else I want like Windows 7
pretty much does everything I want so
why bother I guess why bother creating
more operating systems or newer
operating systems so
um so yeah I I don't even know okay you
know what this is pretty good let's
build that furnace and build some
torches so and I'm running out of food
so I got to find some food so what we
can do is let's just actually get coal
since we're right next to it might as
well instead of burning wood cuz that uh
oh experience oh yeah you get experience
from mining now I remember reading that
somewhere cool all right so now we got
some coal Let's uh burn some hang on to
make torches oh no no we don't need
really need to burn anything but what
what I was going to show you is if
you're stuck without colon it's night
time what you can do is put planks here
and put wood here
and you'll see in a second that apart
from these being very inefficient fuel I
don't even know if that'll be enough
yeah it will um what you'll find is you
get uh charcoal and what you can do with
charcoal is actually use it in the same
way that you would use um oops is to
actually use it in the same way that you
would
use um normal you know
coal where the hell did the charcoal go
here it is um which is just you know
putting it like onto a stick like this
and you can get torches as well so
that's a pro tip if you didn't know that
that's your pro tip of the day by The
Cho and um I don't really like this
place so we're going to get the hell out
of here and uh find a better place to
spend the night so
um yeah that's just about going to wrap
up this video and I'll see you guys next
time
goodbye